alors il ya vraiment une question qui
m'est arrivé rapidement lisant votre
livre par rapport au harcèlement dont
était victime votre fille n'avait pas
vous n'avez pas à vous n'avez vous pas
eu envie vous même de vous faire justice
par la violence ou par l'intimidation au
moins con qu'on sait qu'il ya eu des
erreurs ou harceleuse vous meurtrier
d'enfants sauvages timide avait sinon
les jeunes filles la brutalité la
violence des réactions que j'ai eus ces
violences deux parents autour on peut
comprendre c'est de la retirer de la
tout voilà c'était ça ce qui est ce que
je dis dans le livre peut-être une
erreur parce que finalement les enfants
qui l'ont harcelé je ne méritais pas la
peine de mort voilà ils n'ont pas eu
grand chose
ma fille elle a été viré du lycée si
j'ose dire elle n'a pas été viré du
lycée on l'a changé ni ccl qu'on a
d'ailleurs vous l'interrogez vous dites
est ce que tu crois qu'on a bien fait de
temps levées et elle dit je sais pas oui
parce que ça beaucoup de gens et parler
après avec des beaucoup d'options une
habitude clinique de ça et qui disent
qu'en général les enfants harcelés ou un
moment et 10 mais non c'était pas du
harcèlement
pourquoi parce qu'on a honte des
victimes on n'aime pas ça donc il ya une
aurait pu dire l'idée d'avoir été
victime mise au mini miss mots ma fille
n'a pas été arrêté j'étais là au moment
je sais en fait j'étais là quand tout à
fait mais j'ai assisté en direct un peu
ce qui se passe et ça allait pas très
bien du tout donc je pense qu'il s'est
passé quelque chose
mais non même quoi vous vous iriez vous
venger selon mais en tant que parents
parfois on peut imaginer la tentation
d'aller à la sortie de l'école et de
dire attends je vais repérer les 2 3 kg
mais ça je dirais que ce que dirait que
dire du tout ce qui a gâché oui mais
c'est aussi vous savez le harcèlement
c'était pas du harcèlement physique on
l'a poignardé un c'était c'était dû à du
harcèlement mental qui à un moment de
bien sûr ici une toute petite chose qui
a des grandes conséquences
donc ça mérite pas non plus à prison
voilà ça que je veux dire alors on
commence vraiment maintenant seulement à
parler de phobie scolaire avant on
n'avait pas de nom pour ça déjà pourquoi
on a mis autant de temps
est-ce que vous pensez que aujourd'hui
on est armé contre ça et notamment du
côté de l'éducation nationale qui elle
ne reconnaît pas vraiment la phobie
scolaire
je crois que l'éducation nationale c'est
une industrie c'est à dire que elle fait
des élèves plus ou moins matheux plus ou
moins
orthographié mais voilà elle se
débrouille en elle en produit plusieurs
dizaines de milliers par an bon gré
malgré tout ce qui est tout ce qui est
un peu défectueux ou où différents elle
n'en veut pas donc l'éducation nationale
ne s'occupe pas des enfants pour moi ça
ne m'intéresse pas sur ce qu'il peut se
passer des tas de choses dans les cours
d'école sans que personne ne voit ce qui
se passe les enfants ne sont pas l'objet
de l'éducation nationale à mon avis
après à l'extérieur on est en train
d'essayer de comprendre de quoi il
s'agit parce que c'est en train d'enfler
il y en a énormément et il ya et vous
savez dit l'histoire des problèmes psy
chic c'est une vraie histoire il y avait
à la fin du 19ème il y avait des
dizaines de milliers femme hystérique et
qui partait dans des pâmoisons
incroyable c'est fini maintenant
donc peut-être que la phobie scolaire
n'entendra plus parler dans dix ans dans
30 ans j'en sais rien je suis pas sûr
qu'une fois sur mes mais en tout cas on
est en train aujourd'hui de de
comprendre comment ça se passe la phobie
scolaire l'inquiétude c'est la phobie
sociale ce cancer que l'enfant se
coupent beaucoup de tôles de ses affidés
saison que cela me jean-michel au
travers de l'expérience que vous avez
vécue de l'analyse que vous en faites un
parent dont l'enfant est soumis à un
harcèlement et qui fait l'objet d'une
phobie scolaire
quels conseils vous donner alors si si
déjà s'il arrive à faire le diagnostic
qui a une phobie scolaire ils sont très
fort parce que c'est pas facile de faire
la distinction entre un enfant
paraissait aucun dsp d'allemands ya
aucune envie de l'école nos cousins
d'avoir très très mal au ventre et un
enfant phobique donc déjà il faut
arriver à cette déduction mais il est
évident que on est traître est perdu et
qu'il faut trouver les bonnes personnes
pour moi les bonnes personnes c'est soit
des psys qualifié et qui ont une
expérience clinique de ça mais ça ça se
trouve pas sous le sabot d'un cheval et
ça ne se trouve pas partout donc ce que
je ferais moi ce que je n'ai pas fait ce
que j'habitais paris donc ces dix ans
puis savez j'avais une j'avais joué
j'avais une grande commande et une
grosse expérience de tout ce qui est
d'ordre occident que c'était pas très
compliqué pour moi de tirer les fils
mais je pense qu'il faut se rapprocher
d'une association qui s'appelle
association phobie scolaire va inscrire
sur notre soluce ceux qui souhaitent
avoir la vie ont des correspondances
dans chaque région et qui eux je pense
peuvent vraiment aider les parents à
prendre la chose et à cadrer un petit
peu le problème si vous avez
moindre doute donc on va vous inscrire
le nom de l'association phobie scolaire
l'association phobie scolaire en mettra
le lien comme ça si éventuellement vous
avez un soupçon voilà n'hésitez pas et
puis ça peut forcément et et des justes
dernière question parce qu'on voudrait
que tout aille bien
est ce que louise va bien louis je vais
très bien sauf qu'elle ne va pas à
l'école
toujours pas alors c'est pas une boutade
c'est carrément moi je suis libre ça
pourrait être beaucoup plus grave il ya
des enfants qui ont des histoires
extrêmement plus grave que celle ci je
suis bon bain elle va pas l'école donc
soit elle va réussir à y retourner parce
que là alors un destin c'est normal
d'enfants français d'aujourd'hui soit il
n'arrivera pas il faudra qu'elle fasse
son chemin sans l'école ce qui me paraît
tout à fait possible ce qui est faisable
de l'association bon en tout cas on je
me pète peux me permettre au nom de
l'équipe de l'embrasser
[Applaudissements]